Prof: We're coming to
the end of the course,
and the last couple of
lectures, the last few are
social issues and then we'll
have a very short time for
environment, unfortunately.
Today we're going to talk about
abortion.
It's kind of a unique topic in
the sense that in the United
States it's--
if you have a global
perspective, in most of the
world abortion is not a big
controversial issue.
In the United States it's just
gone sky high as kind of the
central issue in the American
debate on values.
It has tremendous political
significance.
Large numbers of people vote
for a candidate for,
say president,
based solely on whether they
are pro-choice or pro-life.
One of the things you've got to
figure out, or try to,
is why has this become so
important an issue.
I think one of the reasons is
that it encapsulates
diametrically opposed views of
our roles in everyday life.
People perceive it as an
everyday kind of issue.
What are the roles that I'm
talking about?
Sex roles, work roles,
husband and wife roles,
motherhood and fatherhood
roles;
all of those--how you perceive
yourself in those roles will
very much determine how you feel
about the abortion debate.
For instance,
both sides in the debate agree
that the issue is about murder.
A pro-lifer sees images of a
three month old fetus,
which even though only about
the size of your finger they
see--
they're having visuals of blown
up photographs and I'm sure
you've all seen those things and
it already looks quite baby
like,
and thinks of it of being
dismembered and murdered.
A pro-choicer also sees it
about murder,
but she, in her mind,
sees a young woman,
maybe herself,
in a back alley abortion,
being butchered and possibly
murdered.
Almost everyone of the older
generation of pro-choice women
has either themselves had an
abortion,
or has had a friend who has had
an abortion,
and they perceived it as
lifesaving,
or if it was a back alley,
unsuccessful one,
as a life depriving situation.
Both sides agree that the issue
is about babies and motherhood.
A pro-life mother thinks that
babies are so precious that
whenever they come they will be
loved and wanted.
There is no such thing as an
unloved or unwanted baby.
A pro-choice mother thinks that
babies are so precious that they
should only be had when the
woman really wants the baby and
is in the situation in life
where they have resources to
take care of the baby.
Both sides agree that the issue
is about sex.
A pro-life woman thinks that
sex is so special that it should
be guarded by strong religious
and social controls so that it
always has an almost sacred
character.
A pro-choice woman thinks sex
is so special that it should be
freed from worry about pregnancy
and disease so that it can be
enjoyed as a unique sharing of
intimacy.
Both sides agree that the issue
is about the status of women.
Pro-life women think that women
are so important that their
special life role of motherhood
must be protected.
Pro-choice women think that
women are so important that they
should have every bit as much
control over their life roles as
men have.
Just viewed in that way,
one of the interesting things
about this abortion debate is
that the two sides on--
if you really get down to what
the fundamental values of the
two sides are,
they're not different.
They apply them differently.
They're thinking of different
instances, of different real
situations in which to apply
these rather same kinds of
fundamental human values.
All right, well obviously this
is not a philosophy course and
not in the slightest set up to
debate the pros and cons of
abortion,
and that's also a kind of
sterile debate.
Anybody--has anybody changed
their mind about abortion since
they were knee high to a
grasshopper, in the class?
I don't want to know which
direction you went.
One has changed her mind,
two have changed their mind.
That's a high ratio.
Does anybody know anybody who's
changed their minds,
except for yourself of course,
one or two more people;
three another one.
I mean there's so much about
abortion out there and yet
people's attitude toward it is
set very early in life,
by again, these very
fundamental images of what we're
talking about when we're talking
about abortion.
No matter how it's argued,
people basically don't change
their opinions.
I'm not going to debate pros
and cons at all.
I'm going to give you as many
facts about abortion as I can
explain to you:
the demography,
and the biology,
and the statistics,
and all of that kind of stuff.
There are a number of important
things that you should know
about abortion.
The first is that induced
abortion is common;
it's a very frequent situation
in the world.
There's one abortion for every
3.2 live births,
so that's 1 in 3.
Each year about 3% of women in
childbearing ages have an
abortion,
and if you consider a 30 year
reproductive lifespan with each
woman having a 3% chance each
year that's 90%.
That means that,
in the world,
the average woman has a 0.9
chance, very close to one.
Basically, for every woman in
the world, there's one abortion
in her reproductive lifetime.
Of course this is an average,
some women have many more,
and some women have none.
There are three,
actually three or four standard
ways of measuring and expressing
the frequency of abortion.
One is simply the number of
abortions in the world,
or in the country,
or whatever you want.
The latest estimate,
all of these latest estimates
come from 2003.
About every five years people
try to tally up abortion
statistics from around the world
and that's a very difficult job
because wherever its illegal,
you have very great difficulty
getting statistics.
In many places--especially
where there's religious
opposition to abortion they--the
statistics include it as
'menstrual regulation.'
That means a woman has missed
her menses and,
of course, everyone knows
that's a good thing,
so you have to restore the
menses and you do exactly what's
an abortion.
Everybody in the country will
understand what's going on,
but the statistic is menstrual
regulation.
Depending on what's happening
in the country,
you usually have to add one
part of the government
statistics about menstrual
regulation to another part which
says abortion.
Anyway, there are lots of
problems in collecting these
numbers but they're probably
fairly decent because they're
very sophisticated--
demographically very
sophisticated people are the
ones that try to make these best
estimates.
The number of abortions in the
world is now considered to be 42
million per year and the number
has stayed in that range,
the 40 to 50 million range,
for at least the last two
decades,
when there's fairly good
collection of the statistics.
So that's the number.
The abortion rate is defined as
the abortions per 1,000 women in
reproductive ages which is
usually taken as 15 to 44,
or 15 to 49.
For the world it's 29 per 1,000.
So, every year,
per 1,000 women,
29 have an abortion.
That's the 3% that I mentioned
earlier;
if it was 30 it would be
exactly 3%.
Both the highest rate and the
lowest rates are found in
Europe.
Western Europe has 12 abortions
per 1,000 women per year;
Eastern Europe has four times
as many, 44 per 1,000 women per
year.
It's interesting that of the
whole world,
within Europe,
which we sometimes consider a
cultural entity,
it isn't with respect to
abortion, the highest and lowest
numbers are found in Europe.
Another way of expressing it is
the abortion ratio which is the
abortions per 100 live births,
and that's what I told you
before.
One abortion for every 3.2 live
births.
In the world,
that comes out to 31 per 100
and this ranges from 12 in
middle Africa,
it's a low rate,
to 105 in Eastern Europe,
again Eastern Europe has the
highest in the world.
Note that 105;
we're talking about abortions
per live births.
When you have 105 abortions per
100 live births,
there are more abortions than
live births.
So, at 100 per 100,
half of pregnancies are
terminated with an abortion.
Interestingly,
the abortion rate is the same,
is very closely the same,
independent of whether you're
in a developing country or a
developed country.
The rate in developed countries
is 26 per 1,000 and in
developing countries it's 29 per
1,000;
not a huge difference.
China, which everyone worries
about the forced abortions
there, has about 20% of the
world's population and has about
20% of the world's abortions.
Another--the last number that
I'll tell you about that people
calculate,
is what's called the total
abortion rate,
which is calculated exactly in
the same way as the total
fertility rate.
You take the age specific
abortion rate and add it up,
and it's the number of
abortions that the average woman
would have in her lifetime if
she continues with the rates
that are present at the time you
collect the statistics.
Again, I mention this,
in the world it's 0.9 very
close to 1, the average woman
will have 1 abortion in her
lifetime.
It ranges from a low of 0.2,
one abortion per every five
women in several countries,
to a high of 1.7 in Cuba,
almost two abortions per woman
in Cuba.
Well I'll talk later about a
very interesting situation in
Cuba.
Over time, as I said,
the number of abortions is
really, on the big scale,
a couple of decades,
staying pretty constant.
But, from the last compilation
in 1995, the estimate was 46
million abortions and now it's
down to 42 million abortions.
There has been a very small
drop in the number of abortions.
Where do you think all of that
drop has occurred?
Eastern Europe;
again they had an extremely
high abortion rate,
it was the mechanism of
contraception there,
and they're gradually becoming
accustomed to contraception so
their abortion rate is going
down,
three-quarters of the change in
the whole world is all due to
Eastern Europe.
The United States looks pretty
much like the rest of the world.
There's 1 abortion for every
3.2 live births here which is
exactly the number that is the
average for the world.
In the United States there are
1.3 million abortions in again
2003, the last time those
statistics were collected.
The rate is 21.3 abortions per
1,000 women.
If you look per woman,
the U.S.
looks a little better than per
births,
that the total abortion rate
for the United States is 0.64
per woman,
that's mean two-thirds of--the
average is two-thirds of women
will have an abortion during
their lifetime,
whereas, the world is closer to
one.
So, we have a somewhat lower
rate, and again,
the difference is the use of
contraception and I'll talk
about that later.
The United States,
although somewhat better than
the world average in this,
is not nearly as good as 0.2;
remember I said ours is 0.64.
Belgium, Germany and
Switzerland all are down at 0.2,
so less than a third of the
number of abortions per woman
that we have.
A cohort of 1,000 women going
through their reproductive life
will have 639 abortions,
and that's assuming,
we currently have been having a
reducing rate of abortion,
here it presumes that that rate
will stay down.
Expanding out to the world
again, abortion can be a major
method of fertility control,
especially when a country first
goes through its fertility
transition.
One of the fastest fertility
transitions in the world was in
Japan, of all places.
Where they halved the
birthrate--the birthrate in
Japan was cut in half between
1947 and 1957,
in ten years it went down to
half, from 34 per 1,000 women to
17,
and it's remained at that level
more or less until 1979 and now
it's getting even lower.
Here is--this is the
interesting case of Japan.
This is the years
1949--remember MacArthur,
the U.S. Administration of
Japan was still sort of tailing
down at that time and we're
looking at a ten year span.
This is the number of
pregnancies, which is births
plus abortions,
and you'll notice that during
this time,
during this ten year time,
the number of pregnancies
really does not change an awful
lot;
notice 2,700 to
2,900,2,600,2,800,2,800,2,600.
So the number of pregnancies
does not change.
But look what happens to
abortion.
It gets legalized here and very
rapidly it goes from 100 to ten
times as much.
Correspondingly,
the births go down,
so abortion goes from an
insignificant fraction of births
to a very--
so much, much closer to the
number of births.
In this case,
it was legalization of abortion
that sort of,
boom.
caused the Japanese birthrate
to fall.
There was no coercion involved
it was purely a legalization
step.
In many places,
abortion is the method of birth
control.
So, in the Soviet Union,
the official statistics,
before it fell apart,
were that there five to eight
abortions lifetime per woman.
In the Ukraine it was ten to 12
abortions per woman.
The immigrants that come to
America say that's nonsense.
That it was 20 to 30 that
everybody they know had 20 to 30
abortions lifetime.
Japan also, because,
although they legalized
abortion very early,
they didn't legalize the pill
until just a few years ago.
They legalized it when Viagra
came out and the men demanded to
get Viagra.
-- They have a very good
national health plan,
it's all free and very careful
and very good,
and men wanted free Viagra.
Then it became politically
impossible to keep the women
from having the pill,
but pay for men's Viagra.
So Japan legalized it very
recently, the pill,
and their abortion rate has
always been extremely high.
In some special circumstances
the abortion rates have gone sky
high.
In 1966, in Romania,
there were 408 abortions for
every 100 live births,
four abortions for every one
live birth.
The history of that is very,
very interesting.
In the whole Soviet Bloc it was
a complex of issues.
Contraception was legal,
it was kind of available but
the manufacturing was terrible.
They had condoms in the various
Soviet bloc countries but they
were so poorly made that the
people called them galoshes,
they just didn't fit.
Plus, the doctors were working
for the government and not paid
very well,
but they could privately,
outside the government
statistics,
they could privately do
abortions and make money on it.
So, the doctors were all
pushing abortion and for a
variety of other reasons.
We'll talk more about countries
in which abortion is by far the
dominant means of birth control.
Legal and medically performed
abortion, by a trained doctor,
is one of the safest methods of
birth control known.
Here is the statistics on this,
this on this,
this is from the--do you know
the Physician's Desk Reference?
For many years all of the birth
control pills had to have this
graph in it.
What do you see here?
This is the annual deaths--four
women per 100,000 non-sterile
women who are either using or
not using birth control.
What you notice,
the really high category,
was the only super duper high,
is women over 40 who smoke;
bad idea, and use the
pill--smoke and use the pill.
That's the pill--the pill is
their method of contraception
and they smoke.
If you're over 40 and you
smoke, don't use the pill,
that's not a healthy thing to
do.
For every other category of
woman, the white bars are larger
than any of the other bars,
and the white bar is not using
contraception at all.
What this tells you is,
if they're not using
contraception,
they're going to get pregnant
and that the mortality dangers,
this is deaths,
so this is mortality,
that the mortality dangers from
pregnancy are a good bit higher
than any of the methods of birth
control.
Student:  What year was
that from?
Prof: What?
Student:  What year was
this from?
Prof: This is,
I think, about 1990 and
hasn't--well what has changed is
that--
let me finish and I'll tell you
what's changed since then.
The safest is these little
black bars,
which you can hardly see,
which is traditional
contraception which is condoms
is what they're talking about,
backed up by abortion.
That is the safest of all
methods, and then the other
methods like diaphragm and
condom,
IUD, pills for non-smokers,
abortion only,
are all sort of low but
intermediate.
The story is,
with the exception of older
women who smoke,
the worst thing you can do is
not use any method.
That's dangerous.
The best thing you can do is
use a condom backed up by
abortion.
That's surprising because
there's so much popular myth out
there that misconstrues these
facts.
Now what has changed is that
this data was taken in the
earlier days of birth control
pills which were high dose,
and you've probably heard about
this.
They used to have very high
dose because it was new,
they didn't know about it,
and they wanted to be sure.
The main thing was to prevent
pregnancy.
Then they realized they could
get away with lower and lower
doses and the pills nowadays
have much lower doses so there
are much less side effects.
All of these columns would
probably be way,
way down from what they were,
and that's what's changed.
When you go the developing
world, this is United States
data, when you go to the
developing world of course
pregnancy itself is much more
dangerous.
Childbirth is much more
dangerous so what you see is
these white bars go an awful lot
higher depending on the country.
If you're in the middle of
Africa they're very high,
if you're in other places
they're pretty much like the
United States level.
Student:  These are
deaths associated with deaths
while giving birth or these are
deaths from side effects of the
contraceptives?
Prof: Both,
both, both, all of the above.
Okay not only--so this just
shows you immediate mortality
and it's clear what's going on.
Abortion apparently has no long
term clinical effects
whatsoever.
There's no physical affects,
again we're talking about
proper medically done abortions,
sterile abortions,
properly done,
and there are no long term
clinical effects,
neither physical nor
psychiatric.
It doesn't make women sterile,
doesn't increase the chance of
sterility, it doesn't cause you
to go crazy later;
none of that stuff is
statistically true.
Of course there are women who
either having an abortion or not
having an abortion,
go through all these bad events
but statistically they're the
same.
The number of women who've had
an abortion and eventually go
sterile would be the same as
those who have not had an
abortion and eventually go
sterile.
Now that's medical sequelae.
What the emotional content of
having an abortion is,
that varies tremendously by
country.
We'll talk about some countries
where it's absolutely like a
non-event,
having an abortion,
and other places,
and other individuals where if
their own ethics,
their own morality,
their own desire for a child,
their religion,
if it really is opposed to
abortion,
then there can be a lot of
emotional difficulty with it.
But that's not a thing to do
with the abortion itself,
it's to do with the,
shall we say,
the moral context in which that
woman perceives the abortion to
have been done.
Along with this the--So,
you have these generally quite
high rates of abortion around
the world and the question is,
what are the determinants of
that rate?
What makes the rate higher?
What makes the rate lower?
Many people believe that
religious proscription,
that the religion of the
country is what is the
determining factor,
but it's not.
For instance,
in Europe among Catholic
countries,
Belgium has one of the lowest
rates in the world 6.8 per
1,000,
and Hungary another Catholic
country has one of the highest
34.7 per 1,000 so you span the
whole range.
Among Muslim countries,
Bangladesh has one of the
lowest rates 3.8 while Turkey
has six or seven times that
rate.
Again, the Bangladesh rate is a
little confused because of--they
use a lot of menstrual
regulation there.
The U.S.,a largely,
though not-exclusively,
Protestant country,
has about the same rate as
Turkey.
Turkey is essentially all
Muslim, of course.
People believe that the
Catholic Church,
of course, teaches that
abortion is a mortal sin,
its murder.
But, in the U.S.
the abortion rate for
Protestants which is 17 per
1,000 is lower than for
Catholics, 24 per 1,000.
As far as one can tell,
Catholics, because of the
church, slightly underuse birth
control, so, as compensation,
they slightly overuse abortion.
The error bars in all these
basically mean that there's a
barely detectable difference
between say Protestants and
Catholics within America,
within any one country.
There are two issues of why the
Catholic rate is higher.
Yeah.
Student:  Are these
lines per person or per 1000?
Prof: This is per 1,000.
Those are numbers per 1,000;
per 1,000 women of reproductive
age not per 1,000 babies.
The Catholic thing is
most--most of the difference in
that statistic is that there's a
large Hispanic population in
America which happens to
Catholic and has a higher
abortion rate than native born
women,
so that is the most of the
reason why the Catholic rate is
higher.
It's also--you can't tie it
down to legal proscription,
whether abortion is legal or
not legal.
You can't tie that down as a
determining factor in abortion
either.
About half of the abortions in
the world are illegal.
The old statistics used the
word illegal,
but now there is such a variety
of legal rules and such a
variety of situations in each
country where it's legal or not.
Now different states in
different countries,
like in Mexico,
Mexico City has one law,
each state can have a very
different law,
so it gets to be difficult to
describe legality and that's all
tied in with the safety which
we'll come back to.
You see sometimes statistics
about safe abortion,
sometimes statistics about
legal abortion,
and--usually they fit right on
top of each other.
About half of abortions in the
world are illegal,
the other half are legal,
and so for instance in Europe
abortion is generally legal
everywhere under a very wide
range of conditions,
and its abortion rate is 28 per
1,000.
In Africa where it's illegal
almost everywhere it's 29,
so again, no difference.
The lowest rates in the world
are in western--
in northern Europe where
abortion is accessible with few
restrictions so the total--
basically the total legality of
abortion is in a place where the
rates are very low.
Up to 2007 abortion was banned
in Mexico, so it was totally
illegal everywhere Mexico.
Nevertheless,
the number of abortions rose by
50% between 1990 and 2006 with a
constant legal situation of
illegality.
In 2006, Mexico's abortion's
rate was 40% higher than the
U.S.
rate next door.
Here you have three countries
that are all in a line Canada,
the U.S., and Mexico.
Canada has much lower,
and the United States is in the
middle and Mexico--those two are
legal;
in Mexico it's illegal and it
has the highest rate of all.
Of course I should warn you,
and you probably realize it,
that saying that abortion
doesn't--you can't--
the legality is not the
determining factor,
these intercontinental
comparisons,
or country comparison are not
terribly informative because so
many--
between say Mexico and the
United States,
or between Africa and Europe,
there are so many variables,
so many socioeconomic
variables, education,
medical care,
standard of living,
all of this varies
tremendously.
The difference in abortion
rates is not to be found in the
legal or illegal nature,
but in some of those other
characteristics.
In most countries abortion is
legal,
and as of a few years ago,
61% of the world's people lived
in countries where abortion is
permitted,
basically without restriction
or for a wide range of reasons.
Only 25% live in places where
abortion is largely illegal.
These are largely Latin
America, some of the Muslim
countries, and Sub-Saharan
African countries.
Abortion is becoming legal in
more places.
From 1985 to 1998,19 nations
significantly liberalized their
abortion laws and only Poland
de-legalized abortion,
which had to do with its
independence basically from the
Soviet Union at the time.
That was 1985 to 1998.
From 1998 to 2007,
again the latest data,
16 nations liberalized their
abortion laws and two
territories and one state in
Australia liberalized its
abortion laws,
and in Mexico I mentioned.
Mexico City has now made
abortion in the first 12 weeks
legal and that was in 19--
2007 I believe,
and than a few states in Mexico
has followed that,
so Mexico is now a split place.
In this 1998 to 2007 time frame
El Salvador and Nicaragua,
which already had a very
restrictive abortion laws went
to absolute,
under no circumstances,
abortion is totally--
no rape, no death--health of
the mother,
no exceptions in Nicaragua and
El Salvador.
In contrast to the safety of
legal abortion,
where abortions--when it's
legal it's almost always in a
proper medical situation.
When it's illegal,
it's an extremely dangerous
procedure.
There's something like 67,000
abortion related deaths a year
and that leaves 220,000,
a quarter million children
without their mothers.
As you may know,
when it's illegal,
the main procedure is inserting
something up the uterus and
scraping around to try to
dislodge the endometrium and the
fetus.
Well, if you're scraping around
in there with a pointed stick or
a hangar or something,
you're liable to puncture the
uterine wall and make a hole
between the inside of the
uterus,
which is open through the
vaginal canal to the outside,
and the peritoneal cavity,
the inside of your body and so
infection gets through that and
so the main route isn't--
the main reason why
abortion--illegal abortion is so
dangerous is that non-sterility
of whatever it is that's
inserted,
plus it's pointed usually,
and they break right through
the uterine wall.
In addition,
you may know that the fallopian
tube is open into the peritoneal
cavity because the ovary,
which releases the egg is--it
sits right on top of the
fallopian tube and the egg is
released into the peritoneal
space,
the body fluid here and it's
supposed to drop down into the
fallopian tube and cilia push it
down.
That's an opening so if you get
something unsterile into the
womb and then the bacteria can
swim upstream and get into the
body and then you're into sepsis
and you very likely die.
It's a very dangerous procedure
when done not properly.
There are very good statistics
showing that the main
determinant of the maternal
death rate from abortion is its
legal status.
Here again, although I don't
think I showed this slide,
so here is places where
abortion is legal,
here's the abortion rate,
this goes back to saying that
the legal situation doesn't
determine the rate of abortion.
Here are various abortion legal
places and the rate is about 6
to 26,
and here it's illegal and you
have the range of 23 to 52,
so ballpark double or triple
this rate,
so it's illegal.
These are all South America.
This is all Europe,
Japan, Australia,
United States,
very developed countries.
Countries that are partially
developed shall we say.
The illegality correlates with
the abortion rate but it's
almost certainly not the cause,
certainly being illegal is not
causing these high abortion
rates.
Now when you go over and look
at the maternal deaths you see
that there are ten,
the developed regions have an
average of ten,
whereas in Latin America you
have up in the 100 and 200,
and even up to 300 range.
You go to Africa it's 650.
There the illegality really
does make a difference in the
maternal death rate,
that's the dominant effect of
making something illegal is--
doesn't change the abortion
rate and we have a number of
examples,
but it changes the maternal
death rate very,
very clearly.
The most extreme example of
this and the clearest example of
this is from Romania.
Romania had during--after World
War II when it was a Soviet
puppet state,
as I told you,
the abortion rate was
extraordinarily high,
like four abortions for every
one live birth.
Because--well they had a
dictator then,
Nicolai Ceausescu,
who you've undoubtedly have
heard of,
and he decided that for the
glory of greater Romania there
should be more Romanians,
he wanted a big strong state,
so he went on a pronatalist
campaign.
Abortion was immediately
criminalized,
contraceptives became very hard
to get hard, they wouldn't
import them, they didn't
manufacture them.
So what he did was that all
women between 18 and 45 were
rounded up at their workplace,
remember this is a socialist
state so almost all the women
worked,
they were rounded up at their
workplace,
and subjected to a
gynecological examination.
If they were not
pregnant they had to explain to
the government why they were not
pregnant.
It was about as intrusive a
pronatalist campaign as you can
imagine.
It's somewhat the mirror image
of China's anti-birth campaign,
and Romania had the plus
campaign.
Anyway, what happened
immediately--so previously 80%
of pregnancies had been
ending--had been terminated with
abortion.
Abortion disappears,
and was legal,
abortion had been legal,
and boom the birthrate does
indeed go up;
nothing like by a factor of
five but something like a factor
two as I remember but I
want--should--check that.
Then, very rapidly,
women set up networks of
illegal abortion providers and
the birth rate goes up and the
birth rate comes back down and
it ends up somewhat higher than
it had been beforehand,
but not enormously higher.
The maternal death rate is what
changed.
It rose to 200 per 100,000 live
births, from a number in a
developed country that was
something in the tens or
twenties.
It ranged up to ten times that
amount.
The infant mortality rate,
because these mothers didn't
want these children,
presumably, the infant
mortality rate rose to 83 deaths
per 1,000 from--
Japan's rate is 4.8,
the U.S.
is 8.9, so it rose to 83.
So again, something like a ten
times increase in infant
mortality.
The main effect of
de-legalizing abortion was a
temporary rise in the number of
births but a long term increase
in maternal mortality and infant
mortality,
a massive increase.
By the time abortion--of course
when they got free of the
dictator--
it was legalized again and
then, by that time,
things had come back a little
to normal.
But still, the maternal death
rate,
as soon as they legalized
abortion,
the maternal death rate dropped
by a factor three,
so that's Romania's nice
example.
In South Africa,
more recently,
this was in the late 1960s,
the Romania story.
In South Africa the abortion
law was liberalized and the
incidence of maternal infection
due to abortion dropped in half.
In all cases the major effect
of making abortion illegal is an
increase in complications.
You don't change the abortion
rate, but medical complications,
death of the mother,
and death of the infants.
The fundamental--we've been
going through things that are
not the cause of the high
abortion rates,
it's not the religion,
it's not the legality.
The fundamental causes of--kind
of obvious--is unintended
pregnancy.
You may remember that
these--there are very high rates
of unintended pregnancy.
--Here is a comparison of two
regions,
almost all legal in the
developed countries and in
almost all of Africa it's
illegal and the death rate's an
enormous,
enormous difference there.
You may remember these
statistics, just to refresh your
memory, about unwanted
fertility.
This is 71% of living women
want to stop having children.
Yet, as I showed you before,
they have more--
they continue to have children
because they're not using
contraception,
they don't have enough
contraception.
That's Bolivia.
This is from the previous
lecture around the world,
remember this is the line where
people--
this is how many children
people are having,
this is how many they want,
this is the line where they're
equal.
All countries,
all developing countries are
having more children than they
want.
There's a large amount of unmet
need in the world.
The estimate for the world is
108 million women.
Since there's an unmet need,
these women who don't want to
have more children yet do,
that results in some 51 million
unintended pregnancies.
Of those using contraception,
another 25 million happen as a
result of incorrect,
inconsistent use of
contraception or method failure.
You have something like 80
million unwanted pregnancies.
In the world there are 210
million pregnancies annually,
and about 40% of them are
unplanned.
About a quarter of--We know,
from a lot of places,
that when there's an unplanned
pregnancy about a quarter of
them end in abortion.
The main sequence is:
unwanted pregnancy and then
high abortion rate.
Most unintended pregnancies in
the world--most unintended
pregnancies are in the developed
counties.
So there's a difference here
between developed and
undeveloped countries.
Contraception is very available
and highly used in the developed
world,
so in the developed world most
unintended pregnancies are
people who are using
contraception,
and using it fairly accurately,
but there's a method failure,
the contraception just fails.
You have to remember that a
woman is fertile for say 30
years of her life.
She has 12 monthly cycles in a
year, a little bit more
actually, a cycle is 28 days in
principle, but that's close
enough.
In order to not have an
unintended pregnancy her
contraception must be perfect
for 30 years,
12 cycles a year,
that's an awful lot to expect
of a contraceptive,
and contraceptives are just not
that good.
So, in developed countries
also, the main reason for
unintended pregnancy,
it's very heavily--married
women who are using
contraception.
They usually have several
children already,
and the contraception fails.
That's the main reason in
developed countries.
In developing countries where
contraception use is less
prevalent, the main reason is
non-use of contraception.
There is a very strong
relationship between
contraception and abortion.
-- So, we have a country,
most countries,
with this unmet need;
women, before you start
collecting statistics,
want fewer children than
they're having but it's not a
big deal.
Then something changes,
could be a mechanism that we've
discussed the reasons of
cultural change,
and economic change,
or whatever,
and people really start wanting
to have fewer children.
This happened around 1964 in
Korea and you read--and I gave
you one of the stories about how
an example of how this happens
in Korea.
What happens is as women--as
the whole culture changes from
wanting sort of the maximum rate
of fertility to wanting a lower
rate of fertility,
the contraception--the abortion
rate takes off first because in
all these countries abortion is
the traditional method,
the women know it,
and are moderately comfortable
with it,
so you see first the abortion
rate starts going up.
Then, with a short lag,
the contraception rate goes up,
because all the countries
establish national family
planning programs.
What happens is people use more
abortion,
use more contraception,
so they're reducing their
fertility,
but the rate of drop of desired
fertility can be so fast that
even the sum of contraception
and abortion can't keep up with
it,
so both rates keep rising.
Eventually you peak.
Abortion peaks and starts
falling down,
contraception continues upward.
This is the time when the
demand to have less fertility is
more than either method alone
can cope with.
Eventually women--and abortion
is easier because the post--
it's an after the fact method,
but eventually women learn to
use contraception--
learn to use it and learn to
use it properly and so then the
abortion rate declines as the
contraception rate continues on
up to very high levels,
and most of the difference here
is women who want to get
pregnant or something.
You have this trade off.
You have, in an early stage,
both of them rise together and
at a later stage they do very
divergent things.
You'll see when you get a
polemicized discussion of this,
what you'd hear is right to
life people say,
'contraception is no good,
abortion rises with
contraception' and they use
statistics from this half on
down.
People who are pro-choice say
'no, no, no or are
pro-contraception no,
no, no it goes this way and the
use this half of the graph.
But you get both of these
things.
Korea is one example.
Here is another example of the
relationship between
contraception and abortion in
Bangladesh.
Here is--remember Matlab--you
read about Matlab where they
chose some villages and got a
very strong family planning
program and then other villages
which they left as a control
region.
They had family planning
because they had the government
program, but the government
program wasn't any near as good
as the intervention program.
Here's the control region and a
lot to see here.
First of all this is desired
fertility and that starts at
this level and drops down to
somewhat more than half;
desired fertility in the Matlab
region starts at about the same
level and falls about the same
amount.
The difference between the two
regions is not desired
fertility.
The actual fertility rate drops
here, starts higher and drops a
little faster here,
so that it ends up not very
different.
Again, the difference is not
the actual amount of fertility,
which the number of births
isn't enormously different
between the two regions.
In Matlab--in the experimental
region,
the region where they had the
good program,
the contraceptive prevalence
goes very high or goes rapidly
very high from something like
30%,
more than doubles to 70%.
Whereas, in the other--in the
non-control region you have--
it starts much lower--this
rises very rapidly,
this doesn't change at all for
a number of years,
then the government--actually
the government improves its
program,
it jumps up a little bit.
So it's the contraceptive,
this is a really big
difference,
the contraceptive prevalence is
much lower in the control region
than in the experimental region.
The result is:
here's the abortion ratio in
the region where the
contraceptive prevalence is very
high and here the abortion ratio
goes crazy where they don't
have--
they're not using contraception
efficiently.
Again here you can see in those
two regions the same country,
the same time,
neighboring villages,
neighboring districts that
the--there's this tradeoff.
They either use contraception
or they use abortion.
Both places,
they're wanting fewer children
as time goes on,
but in one case they use
contraception and in the other
case they use abortion.
Here's another example of this,
rather different in Shanghai.
This is a more complicated,
somewhat interesting case.
This is the one-child policy
comes in.
They're only allowed one child,
so they have that child and
then they try to do something to
avoid the second child,
and what they use is
contraceptive methods and they
don't work,
they start with very--let me
get this straight here.
They start with a low use of
IUD which is a really secure
method of contraception and the
abortion rate is very high and
they rather rapidly learn that
IUD is the only really secure
way of not getting pregnant and
then the abortion rate falls
down,
so it's another rather
different situation in which
again the abortion rate and the
effective contraceptive rate are
mirror images of each other.
When you have a high rate of
effective contraception you have
a low rate of abortion.
Latin America shows this same
pattern.
In Latin America abortions have
been practiced for centuries.
It was certainly practiced by
the Incas and the Aztecs.
In 1551 the Bishop of Venezuela
reported to the King of Spain
that the natives did not want
their children to become slaves,
so they aborted them, 1551.
Chile has very good medical
statistics.
At the beginning of Chile's
fertility transition in the
1960s 23% of Chilean women
voluntarily admitted to having
an induced abortion.
Again, remember Chile is very
heavily a Catholic country and
this is not really delving into
medical records or making any
corrections.
This is just asking the women,
Have you had an abortion?'
and a quarter of them say,
yes I've had an abortion.
Not only did they have an
abortion but most of them had
more than one abortion,
up to three,
8.4% of the women had more than
seven abortions.
This is early on.
Ten years later in the 1970s
now it's--
where women are really into
their fertility decline,
they don't want the children,
the average woman has almost
three abortions,
lifetime, so that goes up.
Again, those are the openly
admitted numbers and the real
numbers must have been much
higher.
Again, as in elsewhere,
in Chile almost all the women
were married,
almost all middle class women,
and they already had had four
to six pregnancies,
they already had children,
and experience with pregnancy.
In terms of socioeconomic
levels, middle class women had
more abortions than working
class women.
Married women had a greater
abortion rate than those living
in temporary unions,
and in all--through all this
time abortion was completely
illegal in Chile and it still
is.
Going next door to Peru,
in Lima in the 1970s,
again the time when the
fertility was going down,
when people were wanting fewer
children in Peru,
the yearly increase in the
abortion rate was 24%,
every year there was a 24%
increase in abortion.
In any given year a quarter to
a third of the reproductive age
women would have abortions,
that's one out four,
one out of three women every
year would have an abortion.
Again, it's in this--the really
high abortion rates are when
women are--
or families are starting to
want fewer children and haven't
yet really figured out how to
use contraception.
In contemporary Latin America
abortion,
although it's illegal almost
everywhere and it's almost
universally a Catholic place,
abortion is very widespread.
Latin America as a whole has 1
abortion for every 2 live
births;
remember worldwide and in the
U.S.
it's 1 per 3.2,
Latin American has 1 for every
2 live births.
Eventually there's a
generational change and the
younger women start using
contraception and then the
abortion rate starts to fall.
The Philippines,
another example--in the
Philippines have a very
interesting situation of the
politics.
There's a strong
inter-relationship between the
politics of the country,
the Catholic Church,
and the citizen's use of
contraception.
When Fidel Ramos was President,
one of the early very populist
president's,
he supported family planning
and a quarter of the Filipino
women were using the modern
method.
Since then the desired
fertility has gone down in the
Philippines and now more than
half of Filipino women want some
form of birth control.
But the presidency has changed
and a woman,
Gloria Arroyo Macapagal,
came in and since Ferdinand
Marcos was a strong dictator and
they had strong presidencies but
then,
when he was kicked out for
massive corruption and
dictatorial means,
they now have democratic
elections and the governments
have been quite weak.
They don't have much popular
support and so the government
needs to get legitimacy from
somewhere and in this case they
get legitimacy from the Catholic
Church because,
again, the Philippines is a
very Catholic country.
A fairly open deal was made
between Macapagal and the
archbishop of the Philippines
that the church will support you
if you make abortion illegal and
get rid of the family planning
programs.
Now the government--and that
was taken and she got elected --
and now the government only
supports the traditional family
planning method,
which is withdrawal basically.
This had an effect.
So from 1993 to 1998 in the
five, six year period,
the use of traditional methods
went up by 50% while the use of
modern methods didn't--
actually didn't change much.
When the government pushes
something it often goes up and
all those traditional methods
just plain don't work.
The result was that the number
of abortions in the Philippines
in these years increased by 19%
from 400,000 which was already
high--
from 400,000 it went up to
basically a half a million
abortions.
They're all illegal of course.
As I said in the beginning,
in America abortion is a great
source of controversy.
This is not always the case in
a lot of places,
so there's a lot of literature
now on what they call the
culture of abortion.
Those countries for whom
abortion has a non-controversial
place as a mechanism for
fertility control just as
contraception has a more or less
non-controversial place as a
form of fertility control in say
Europe and America.
I got invited a few years back
to talk to the women's health
class about abortion and--
it was one of the things we
talked about,
and afterwards I was talking
with some students and a
professor with the next class
walks in and he turned out to be
from Russia and he asked us what
are you talking about?
The students had started asking
me questions about--something
about abortion.
He was really puzzled;
he said 'abortion,
why is anybody interested in
that?'
Because in Russia it's just an
ordinary, absolutely ordinary
kind of thing;
in places like Romania,
and I'm sure this is to some
degree true in probably the
whole of eastern Europe.
Remember, I mentioned to you
the old theory that the health
of the body depends on the
humors,
that you've got four humors of
bile,
and choler, and all this other
stuff and it's the balance
that's important.
You have to reestablish--What
the menstrual period does,
everyone knows the worst fluid
is menstrual fluid,
and so you've got to get rid of
that and if you don't--
if you're not periodically
getting rid of menstrual fluid,
the bad spirits humors,
fluids, build up in you and you
get unhealthy.
In places like Romania,
many people,
older less educated people,
believe that it's good to have
an abortion every so often.
Having nothing to do with
pregnancy even,
it's just good to do that to
get rid of this evil humor.
That has persisted as well as a
lot of other really
unbelievable--
almost unbelievable to us,
medical myths and is part of
the reason for that very,
very high abortion rate in
Romania.
In the Ukraine,
when the Soviet Union fell
apart,
the family planning programs
that they had also fell apart,
and so the whole area was left
without effective family
planning.
The International Planned
Parenthood Federation,
their nearest office was in
Bangkok and so they couldn't
help very much.
What they did is,
they said, we'll take just the
city of Moscow because it's most
cost effective to work in a
city,
a lot of people,
we don't have geographic
access,
but, we'll try to provide some
contraception in Moscow.
That left all the other Soviet
Bloc countries with nothing.
The Planned Parenthood
Federation of Connecticut here,
I was associated with them at
the time,
got in contact with the
Ukraine--the whole Ukraine was
left like bereft of
contraception.
Got in touch with the main--the
head and the university in Kiev,
the head of the OB/GYN
Department, a very nice woman,
and started to help her
provide--buy contraceptives here
and ship them abroad.
Actually we buy them
internationally,
very cheap, a cycle of pills is
$.80 on the world market.
A condom is like a penny and a
half, diaphragm is $1.25.
So, if you buy them in the
United States they're expensive.
If you buy them in India or
wherever they're made,
the things are a lot of
cheaper, so we could really help
Ukraine.
What they wanted first
was--because you can't use any
of these things if there's
pelvic infections so they wanted
Monistat and other treatments
for vaginal infections as a
first line and than they could
start dealing with
contraception.
Anyway, this program went on
but it wasn't very successful
and the reason was,
the women were using abortion
and were quite happy with it.
They didn't see anything wrong
with it;
they were used to it,
and no problems,
so why should we change?
One of the things that they
did, and we helped them,
was we got some of these
right-to-life films,
which show, in the goriest way,
what the fetus looks like and
what an abortion is like and you
know are really are way,
way off the deep end and
shipped them to them so they
could show their patients and
say,
'see an abortion is not just
this sort of nothing kind of
event.'
The most interesting case might
be Cuba which has one of the
highest abortion rates in the
world,
78 per 1,000 women per year,
compared to Canada which has
15.5,
for instance,
again that's the two sides of
the United States.
Almost 60% of what they call
known pregnancies are terminated
by abortion.
So they have a long history.
Before 1938 they were very much
tied culturally to Spain,
and Spain was very
conservative.
That was the Franco era;
a very, very right wing
fascist, Catholic dictatorship
and so--
in the Spanish law all forms of
abortion,
induced abortion were illegal,
and Cuba just used that same
law.
It was up until 1938,
and in 1938 they liberalized a
little bit for rape,
likelihood of death of the
mother, or severe fetal
malformation issues.
Despite these restrictions it
was the mechanism of birth
control in Cuba and it was used
widely by all the social
classes.
Well, I'll tell you an
exception to that,
and by poor people and it was
used in the cities and in the
countryside.
So abortion was it.
Contraception starts coming in
but it's a foreign product and
it's expensive,
and you need some medical
knowledge to use it,
so only the upper class uses
contraception,
at this time,
used contraception in Cuba.
At that time a very,
very--few people owned all the
sugar plantations and everyone
else was basically a slave on
the sugar plantations,
so the social gulf between the
rich people using contraception
and the poor people using
abortion was enormous and they
didn't talk to each other.
So there was no social
diffusion of the ideas of
contraception,
so the people just continued
using abortion.
1959 Fidel Castro has his
revolution and he takes over,
and in the beginning he's
anti-abortion,
he still is,
and a lot of events happened
and I'm simplifying a
complicated history.
By 1962 the United States
places an embargo on Cuba,
including medical supplies,
and guess what the Cubans can't
get?
Contraception,
because the United States was
their source of supply,
so abortion gets more
entrenched.
The embargo might have done the
biggest thing to raise Cuban
rates;
no one has good statistics on
that.
While abortion is legal in
Cuba, the government really
wants to reduce it.
In 1998 the Pope visited Cuba
as you probably may remember
from all the headlines and he
talked against abortion,
then, shortly after that,
Castro gave a seven hour
lecture,
worse than me,
a seven hour lecture condemning
abortion as a method of birth
control.
He said it was his duty as a
public figure and a
revolutionary leader to oppose
widespread abortion.
It didn't have any effect on
the people,
and it's very interesting,
there is now a wonderful
article which I actually should
have assigned to you about
what's going on in Cuba.
You have too much reading
already.
The medical--the government and
the medical establishment want
to get people--wean people off
abortion.
In these interviews one of the
things they ask the respondents,
who are women of all ages and
men of all ages,
'well what have you heard from
doctors and healthcare
professionals.'
'Well that's it's dangerous,
that you can die from it.
Just imagine'--that's what
she's heard from the
professionals--'but just imagine
if you had to give birth every
time you got pregnant.
I got pregnant and had an
abortion when I was 15 even
though I was on the pill.
I also got pregnant earlier
when I was using an IUD.'
This was a woman,
who at the time of the
interview was age 30,
and she had--this is after her
fourth abortion.
The people's perception is very
different than what they're
hearing from the medical
establishment and the government
establishment.
It's an absolutely unremarkable
subject for discussion.
One male who is now age 49
said, 'I was about ten
years'--they ask what have
you--do you hear about abortion?
Is it discussed?
He says, 'sure,
I was about ten years old,
I heard about abortion from
people on the street,
also in my house my mom talked
about it with her friends in
front of me.'
Another respondent:
'Around the streets abortion is
a common thing people talk
about.
It's an everyday thing.'
A male aged 23.
"Do you know anyone in
your family, among your friends
who's had an abortion?"
'Yes, an aunt of mine.'
"What did she tell
you?"
'That you don't feel anything,
that they give you the
anesthetic and stuff,
everything goes fine.'
That was a woman of 18 who's
just had her first abortion.
Another respondent,
'yes friends of mine,
they told me that they had it
done and that you don't feel
anything.'
Now that was a 15 year old girl
with her first abortion.
Another respondent,
'my cousin had an abortion,
she told me that nothing out of
the ordinary happened,
that everything went well.'
This is a female aged 21 on her
second abortion.
Another respondent,
'when I was in school,
a friend of mine had an
abortion;
she was fairly young around 13
years old because we were in the
eighth grade.'
"What did she tell you,
how did it go?"
'She told me it went well and
said the anesthetic was fine,
girls talk about that kind of
stuff.'
This was a 31 year old woman on
her fourth abortion.
Another respondent--to the
question, have you heard much
talk about abortion?
'Oh yes, among girls at school.
They don't use anything,'
meaning they don't use any
contraceptives,
'so when they get pregnant the
go to get an abortion.
They talk about it like it's
nothing;
it's like drinking a glass of
water.
Some people have problems when
they get an abortion but most
people don't.
Almost always the procedure
goes fine.'
That's a 17 year old girl after
her first abortion.
It's a very interesting case
because while they're
experienced,
they're hearing one thing from
the government,
the same thing from the medical
community but they know lots and
lots of people who have had
abortions,
a common subject,
and they're not hearing about
any difficulties from it,
or very rarely are they.
The government's pushing
contraception and they use
contraception,
92% of the Cuban women have
used contraception.
That's some time--even among
adolescent girls who are
obviously having a very rich sex
life because they're getting
pregnant all the time,
84% have used some form of
contraception.
It doesn't mean anything to
them, because they're just as
happy with abortion.
So, they're not worried about
getting pregnant so they
sometimes use contraception,
they sometimes don't,
and the reports of when they
use it are almost totally
haphazard.
They'll use it for a while,
they'll stop using it,
they'll start again and they
change methods.
It doesn't even have any--of
course women go through periods
and men too,
when they're in a relationship
having sex or just having a lot
of casual sex,
and the woman will tell you
this and the use of
contraception did not correlate
at all with periods when the
women were having sex.
It's just a total disconnect
and undoubtedly the reason is
that they're perfectly happy
with abortion and it's a fine
backup so they don't have to be
terribly careful about using
contraception.
In fact, much as they're
hearing that abortion is no big
deal,
they're hearing that the other
forms of other contraception are
really not very pleasant.
Here are more answers to survey
questions.
'I don't like the pill because
of extra hormones in the woman's
body,' a male aged 19 says that.
This is a woman:
'No, I don't use any IUD
because my body can't support
it.
It falls out of place.'
"You have used an IUD in
the past?"
'Yes, I had an IUD two
different times and both times
it fell out place.
I have problems with IUDs.'
That's a 37 year old woman on
her second abortion.
IUD causes pain to women.
'After my first pregnancy I had
an IUD inserted,
but I had to have it removed
because it was causing pain.
I started having problems with
my period and a lot of
inflammation,
and when I had sex it was
painful, so I had the IUD
removed,' female aged 35 her
first abortion.
'I had an IUD before,
I had it for two years,
but I had it removed because I
had abnormal menstrual
bleeding,' a 42 year old woman,
fourth abortion.
Another woman,
'sometimes I'll use protection
but the condom broke.
You explain these things to the
doctors and they say that--this
doesn't happen but I'm telling
you it's not a lie.
Sometimes condoms are bad and
they break,' a 19 year old girl
on her third abortion.
At the time of the survey 88%
were practicing contraception at
the time of the survey,
and again, among adolescents
68% were using condoms at the
time of the survey.
Yet, the contraception,
they didn't like it,
it wasn't effective,
and they were apparently just
as happy with abortion.
It's a very interesting thing
and this is repeated in
basically all of the east
European countries,
where again,
they have long experience with
abortion and they don't
particularly see any benefit to
contraception.
Now the standard thing that
you'll hear in America from
everybody, independent of
their--they can be right to life
or pro-choice.
Their thing is that--the idea
is, and I've been sort of saying
that here,
the idea is to replace abortion
with contraception,
that contraception is a better
method of birth control than
abortion.
It's controversial--but now
it's controversial.
Actually, what started me
really looking into this was a
number of years ago I was giving
a lecture,
and I was saying very overtly,
that well it's progress when
contraception replaces abortion.
Now it's not so obvious because
I showed you this one,
that the safest method is
condoms backed by abortion.
It's very--it was very
hard--one student asked me this
question about why is--
why do you think that
contraception is better than
abortion and it's a very,
very hard question to answer
and I won't even try to do this
today.
It's a very difficult kind of
issue.
The final thing that I should
tell you is that one of the
things we worry about is the
population growth rate.
Abortion makes a huge
difference in the global rate of
population growth.
As I told you,
there's ballpark 75 million
increase in the world now.
If the abortion rate is about
somewhere between 40 and 50
million, that means the rate of
world population increase goes
up by 75% or something.
Because abortion is such a
large fraction of the birthrate,
if abortion disappears and is
not replaced by contraception,
the population growth rate goes
crazy.
In the world,
as it is now,
there's probably not any chance
of stabilizing world population
without abortion.
Just on time,
we will continue with the
biology of abortion and some of
the history and philosophical
considerations in the next
lecture.